[Musique]
en juillet 1945 la capacité guerrière du
japon est anéanti les b 29 salariés deux
fois plus de bons que sur l'allemagne
qui a capitulé croise trois matches
combien de temps au japon des faits
peut-il encore tenir en août il subit un
test que n'a pas connue l'allemagne
en attendant la grande invasion final la
bombe atomique
[Musique]
sur hiroshima ce sont soixante-dix mille
vies japonaises qui sont anéantis par
une seule bombe a en quelques minutes
l'effet des radiations portera le nombre
de victimes à 200000 la destruction
totale dans un rayon de 10 km par une
température de 4 mille degrés du jamais
je pensais la démonstration la première
et la dernière j'espère la démonstration
selon laquelle l'armé nucléaire est une
arme de terreur qui vise avant tout les
populations civiles
c'est par une arme militaire
une arme de terreur mais la capacité de
l'arme nucléaire non seulement de
détruire des immeubles de tuer des gens
mais de détruire carrément le passé d'un
pays c'est le passé sa mémoire
historique dansant salle armes
nucléaires en fait ils probablement
l'homme qui toujours la plus
destructrice de toutes les armes dont
dispose l'être humain pour l'instant les
tomboy la bombe d'hiroshima était une
bombe à l'uranium équivalent à 14 milles
tonnes d'explosifs conventionnels les
américains voulaient tester une deuxième
bombe au plutonium
ce sera fat man 80 mille morts à
nagasaki
au dernier moment la vieille capitale
historique kyoto est épargné donc entre
les deux bombes nucléaires plus c'est
tous toutes ces autres villes qui ont
été détruites à part kyoto il ya quelque
chose de très profond dans le psychiatre
japonais d'avoir été comme ça totalement
détruit physiquement et c'était des
civils bien sûr qu'ils ont été détruits
little boy et fat man sont en fait des
bombes expérimental la toute première
explosion atomique s'est déroulée dans
le désert du nouveau-mexique tout juste
trois semaines avant hiroshima
l'implacable machine de guerre est en
marche
une autre chose qui est incroyable c'est
qu'on était à deux doigts d'une
troisième bombe
la troisième bombe était prête en fait
l'armée américaine avait donné l'ordre
déjà de l'expédier à tignes à l'aide de
la base mais truman a arrêté
l'expédition parce qu'il a eu des
remords le 10 août
il voulait il a exprimé qu'ils ne
voulaient plus tuer des civils etc
harry truman qui n'est président que
depuis trois mois ne savais pas que le
bombardement qui l'a autorisée était
nucléaire et la décision du 25 juillet
la décision a été prise le 25 juillet
c'était une décision générale je vous
autorise à utiliser cette bombe est en
fait elle n'est pas signée par truman
elle est signée par l'armée par marchand
par le généralement chaud et il n'y
avait pas de précisions sur le nombre de
villes sur le nombre de bombes
c'était une décision générale et la
deuxième bombe nagasaki dans lequel la
deuxième bombe
truman n'étaient pas informés et ne le
savait pas quand il a il a su après bien
sûr
en fait le seul qui devait le savoir
c'était le premier ministre canadien
william lane mais kenzy king au pouvoir
depuis dix ans il avait signé à québec
en août 1943 avec winston churchill et
franck les nouvelles l'accord secret qui
lançait le fameux projet manhattan son
ministre sidya ou donnent le feu vert du
canada au pentagone le 25 juillet 1945
onze jours avant hiroshima on croit que
le japon aurait capitulé à voir les
bombes mais il fallait le pull hier pour
cole rabbin et ses clips de gardes tu ne
pas en fait le message s'adressait aux
japonais évidemment c'est considéré les
destructions que nous sommes capables de
faire et faisant fait exploser deux
bombes et non pas une
on passe le message que les américains
disposer d'un stock d'armes importants
ce qui n'était pas le cas
l'autre message s'adressait aux russes
donc à staline en particulier ceux ci
annonçait que pour disons les débuts de
ce qui allait être là la guerre froide
les américains a vu une domination d'un
monopole sur la route hier donc pour les
décennies à venir
[Musique]
claude est pas en termes de destruction
en termes de capacité de destruction de
civilisation et de la planète en tant
que tel
l'arme nucléaire demeure l'armé ultime
l'horreur d'hiroshima à dissuader les
pays qui possède l'armé nucléaire de se
servir de bombes des centaines de fois
plus puissantes que celles du japon
mais jusqu'à quand mais ça c'est ce qui
fait peur c'est à dire qu'il reste des
personnes qui sont prêtes à aller
au-delà de ce tabou donc c'est pas un
tabou totalement unanime et il ya un
danger de personnes qui vont perdre la
conscience de ce que ça représente
jusqu'où peut-on se fier aux leaders de
pays comme la chine l'inde le pakistan
la corée du nord entre autres qui
possède l'armé ultime
[Musique]
i
et